how often do you lie and how often do
you think other people lie to you
chances are is a lot more often than you
think there are a number of different
reasons why we lie so we might lie for
personal gain we might lie to avoid
punishment we might lie because we get a
kick out of pulling the wool over
somebody else's eyes so the white lies I
always say are the oil that keeps life's
machinery running smoothly everybody
lies imagine a situation where we told
the truth all of the time I really don't
think we'd last very long we certainly
wouldn't have friends for more than
about 24 hours
[Music]
[Music]
people lie to get rewards and avoid harm
so for example in order to get a good
job you might think I would lie on my CV
you might lie to gain more money people
also lie often because they want others
to see them more favorably in order to
get a better date you might think I
would lie on a dating app
[Music]
according to George Lake off at the
University of California we tend to
interpret evidence differently depending
on our personal beliefs and anything
that challenges that will actually be
ignored or even attacked which might go
some way to explaining why society can
be so polarized research suggests that
when we're married about one in ten of
our interactions is a form of deception
but when we're in the early stages of
getting to know a person or dating them
it can be as high as almost half the
things that we tell the other person
could be deceptive in some kind of way
the most common type of lies that we
tend to tell are the white lies the
protective lies so imagine your partner
is a budding Picasso they come home from
art class one night and they show you
their latest painting that they're very
proud of you take a look at it and go
and they say Oh what do you think of my
painting we would typically go oh yes I
quite like that we wouldn't necessarily
tell the outline truth that we wouldn't
have that on the wall if you paid us to
when we learn to lies children we use
something called the theory of mind
which is our understanding of the
intentions and beliefs of others we also
develop skills such as planning and self
control which help us to help better
porkies Robert Feldman at the University
of Massachusetts found that we life
frequently and we don't even know how
often we do it participants in his study
lied on average three times in a ten
minute conversation when they were
meeting each other for the first time
they weren't aware that they were lying
that much until they watched back the
footage of the interactions we like to
think of ourselves as very honest
truthful trustworthy people so one of
the reasons that we might not be good at
tracking how often that we've lied we
might be under estimating quite a lot
about how often we lie we might
underestimate to protect ourselves to
protect our self-esteem make ourselves
feel better about ourselves you might
think it's okay to lie in certain social
situations I mean what's wrong with
telling someone that they look good
today but our little acts of dishonesty
as harmless as they seem is lying about
small things the start of a slippery
slope there are many famous examples by
which people started with small lies
that seemed to have expanded into bigger
and bigger lives
Bernie Murdoch is one example with his
Ponzi scheme he himself says that he
started with small lies but over time it
became a really big snowball that
expanded so when someone lies they often
feel bad about it because we think lies
are amoral and so if we lie we feel bad
but the thing is that when we have an
emotion and then we encounter the same
stimulus again that triggered that
emotion the amount of emotion that we
feel is reduced if we allow people to
get away with small lies it is possible
that over time they will be more likely
to be more and more dishonest and
actually commit bigger crimes this has
some implication for education for
example trying to stop kids even when
they tell little lies but also for law
enforcement if we stopped small acts of
dishonesty that could potentially over
time make it less likely that people
will commit large acts of dishonesty
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon